[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
good evening
men and women boys and girls from all
around the world i'm mr johnny rotten
the most uncensored and uncircumcised
man in britain and i'm here live and
unleashed you have been
warned
[Music]
appears organized tonight in a special
jubilee show we commemorate her majesty
of the queen's 70 years of service i'll
be joined by stellar lineup of guests
including former sex pistols front man
john lydon and the queen's jockey
frankie de torre
it's been an amazing day and it was
incredibly moving actually and very
emotional in many ways to think here's
this lady 96 years old who came out
after a lot of health issues came out on
the balcony twice to an absolutely
roaring ovation from a packed mall and
she had a beaming smile and like she was
loving every minute of it with her
family there
i'm joined by brian blessing when you're
one-on-one with the queen brian what's
she like
well i mean she finds me very naughty
and we all do i mean she oh you know
i mean when she gave me the ob
what did she say
what did the queen say and she
i mean she said you know
she said mr blessed you know um
wisdom of this
uh
i
i do believe that people have told me
that you imitate me i said no i don't
she said you're such a liar
the queen called you a liar
and so
that
and i then talked about us about her son
charles i work with i'm an ambassador
for him yes saving animals all over the
world it's terrific the inca bloody
marvel yes people a a tremendous he's a
green green green green green we need
him you didn't actually didn't you
actually try and buy camilla from him
well i've always had well let me i'm
going to play you a damning clip where
you literally tell the future queen
console that you tried to buy here watch
this
the chitchat bang bang and she came
backstage and it was christmas and i i
was made father christmas i was naked
underneath my costume and so forth and
she came and sat on my knee and she was
darling darling she said to a husband
yes and she said at
the theater where we were doing it that
had that jerry lane not really the other
one palladium and she sat on my knee and
said and she'd been darling darling she
picked up the phone to child darling i'm
here darling i'm with father christmas
which is brian blessed and i do believe
he's not got any underwear on
i'm sat on his knee and he wants to buy
me and can you work out a prize he said
hello brian he said no no no no no no no
oh she's worthless nothing you can have
for nothing
oh thank you he says i can have you for
nothing oh good i'm yours
and so i've always had this
uh wild relationship as i said working
with him and and doing what did she be
brian what does she mean to this country
what did today mean
about britain yeah i mean when you watch
the the pomp and the pageantry and this
little old lady commanding the attention
of the entire world what does it say
about her
and the country can you give me another
two minutes yes i want to emphasize what
royalty is now i was in heaven the fifth
with ken browner and henry v
was then
um uh
it was then produced in japan and there
was a big premiere with the entire power
of japan government attending the first
night at penn to the fifth ken branagh v
with me as a duke of exeter and i was
going to open this whole thing with
princess sam now princess sam i'm a war
baby
i'm going into you know teljo i'm going
into uh
you know the japanese powerhouse there's
we are arrived there we watch the film
and with princess anne and then she and
i have to go and meet the entire length
and breadth
of all these ambassadors and the and
there also was his highness
the emperor and the empress there the
power of japan i'm gonna call my son
and anne really i did flirt with and she
loves it all the time and she was saying
i said when are we going to get married
oh stop it by somebody
you
i've got to introduce you and she said
oh we'll ask them
this was the power of japan
i mean in front of us
and we went along asking who they were
and they were shaking
i'm talking about japan they rule the
world then
they were shaking at meeting princess
anne it's not amazing and so that one
must be careful one must acknowledge the
power that the royal family have in
their their beatific power and their
sacred power uh
and their bravery the effect they have
on the world yes more than any
government yes people
it translates
but what does the queen in particular
brian say about this country what are
the the values and virtues she
represents which i think are the great
in great britain in many ways but what
does she mean to you in terms of values
well i mean
why don't i i tend to go to shakespeare
all the time
king john is never done
and there's a character in it called the
bastard shakespeare's king john
and in the end the british forces are
retreating
uh and uh the delphi is
going to invade britain and there's king
john and there's the bastard who is the
son of kurdish a great hero
and he says come come come
to the empire join me
uh
at last
um what am i gonna say um
ragers at our heels
but england's princes
have come home again
come the four corners of the world and
we shall shake them
england never shall sit
at the proud foot of a conqueror
i feel
the queen
is our mother
is sacred
omnipotent
and greatly loved by the creator
and this she displays
and she also employs a maximum effect
with a minimum of effort and that is
grace it is she has grace
and we must all pray for her and so
forth we are so damn lucky
to have such a unique
wonderful woman yeah
yeah and
we need her and today we need him more
than ever she's got to go on we need her
she has and it's obviously she's having
a lot of problems with her health but
you'd expect that at her age and she's a
remarkable woman we wish you all the
very best i also wish your wife all the
very best brian it's lovely to see you
please send them all our best friends
it's lovely to see you yeah a great day
to be british it's nice to be here it's
a great day to be british i think it's
time to be proud of our country that's
right we're doing damn well we are we're
bloody marvelous we are i have been
present at the national parks for seven
years our parks are a great success
story
i'm sick of the criticism we're doing
marvelously i agree it's a time to
rejoice
and to rejoice in her health i agree
brian blessing great to see you thank
you very much
i said next of a band of royal duties
but will harry and megan try and steal
the royal limelight from the queen of
the platinum jubilee i'm discussing that
with photographer arthur edwards he's
written him an open letter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in abandoned world duties will harry and
megan try and steal the royal spotlight
over this jubilee weekend for
photographer arthur edwards royal editor
of vanity fair kelly nicholl and
novelist bonnie greer give me their
thoughts
you've written a piece about megan harry
i'm going to come to the moment i want
to start though by talking about this
remarkable bbc documentary last night
because i honestly think it was the best
royal documentary i've ever watched and
me too i thought it was fantastic and
the
and the the king i mean the way he was
playing with his grandchildren i mean
that man was always considered like to
be a stutterer and uh very you know
didn't want the job but my god he came
across as a fantastic and of course the
duke of edinburgh you know absolutely
the slide on the royal yacht with the
kids i mean it was unbelievable and the
queen shot a lot of that fully just said
well that was the great thing wasn't it
katie was that this footage was raw
footage taken by the royals of
themselves these were family home videos
which we've never really seen you have
and you've got to really see them as a
family i think it dispelled so many of
the myths about the queen actually she's
so often seen certainly in those early
days of a mother who was quite aloof
well she she was full of love for her
children there was nothing staged for
the cameras and it was wonderful to see
her and and the young princess margaret
interacting and playing and obviously i
love margaret and the queen together
interacting even when they were very
young and then teenagers and then a bit
later
very close sort of quite mischievous
relationship with each other right yeah
and i think you you've got to see that
dynamic of what they called we four the
queen mother and the king and these two
young daughters enjoying the most
wonderful life i think you're right
about it being the best royal
documentary i mean people might remember
elizabeth r and the royal family
probably not i know some of these people
the power of this was the simplicity it
was of the home footage and then the
queen now
the racing back over her own life and
then the pictures of charles and anne
has taught to them amazing and i mean i
work a lot with prince charles and now i
think about him like that you know and
he was just brilliant it was a great
moment when they played a clip about her
view of the platinum jubilee let's
listen to this i don't know that anyone
had invented the term platinum for a
70th anniversary when i was born
you won't expect it to be around that
long
typically
bonnie greer before we get into probably
slightly more incendiary territory with
the royals let's talk about the queen
for a moment because i i don't really
care whether you're pro monarchy
anti-monarchy in the world you cannot
but have respect for this woman who for
70 years has been on the throne
barely put a foot wrong in that entire
time and does exemplify the very things
she talked about when she was 21 duty
and service
well you know
believe it or not and good evening
everybody believe it or not
my family was royalist my my mother
certainly was
so i grew up with enormous respect for
her and if you you know what you may not
have noticed no one said it the queen's
changed her
exactly that's my point but my next
point is that chimes have changed and we
need to change too because she certainly
has well i think that's a very good
point and after i think the whole future
of the monarchy when the queen sadly the
day comes when she's eventually not with
us is it going to be a very very crucial
one not just very difficult just for
britain but for the world years indeed
and prince charles got a tough job in
fact to uh to keep it on two bit online
and going and of course you know many of
the countries uh that where the queen is
head of state will will pull out you
know i mean i think certainly australia
will maybe new zealand perhaps canada
but it's going to be a change and but
the principals will cope with that he
said when we left barbados last year
when they gave up the queen he said well
it's what they want
and that's fair enough so
there will be changes but and prince of
wales is already thinking about that
well he's i think he'll be a much better
king than some people said i think so
too he's a he's a lovely man he's a ways
and of course he'd never he's tireless
and if you think of very much piers he's
a visionary you know when he was 25
years ago talking about organic food and
people calling crazy and there every
store you go to now has got organic food
and complementary medicine and everybody
takes some sort of complimentary
medicine
and uh and so you know as a visionary
and i followed him and when i started
doing this job i didn't care less about
what i was doing just get pictures of
anything but slowly listening to him the
way where he's presented his speeches
the way he asked the
people in brazil and malaysia not to rip
up the rainforest and and almost and and
you know the plastic in the ca fights
for that he does and he's been ahead of
his time on a number of these things
katie
we're going to see on the balcony on
thursday morning the trooping the color
a streamlined
royal lineup you're not going have harry
and megan or andrew or the others who've
been
into dodgy territory in the last few
years you're gonna have the main players
yeah the queen and you have charles and
camilla and then you have kate and
william and that is the that's the line
of succession right there but you don't
forget you're going to have the duke of
kent the gloucesters the wessex princess
tips it's really about the main event it
is but it's interesting piers because
when you think back to the diamond and
um you'll remember this as well
it was very much about the streamlined
royal family it was just the queen the
cambridges
charles and camilla so i think this is
very important to the queen that she is
having an opportunity to thank those
that those that she calls my substitutes
the people who have stood
if you count the number of duties these
are the ones who put the yards in two
who won't be on the balcony but are
coming in
are megan and harry um you've written a
pretty
robust and direct letter to them in
tonight's son in which you basically
plead with them not to try and steal the
limelight from the queen yeah because if
they publish a picture when the queen
meets lilybet that will wipe everything
else out you know that's that that's
what i'm thinking you know everyone's
talking to the editor tonight and saying
that that picture will just
scream in and everything the queens are
trying to achieve with this you know
doing her very best to make appearances
and
it would just go to pieces and i just
hope she doesn't turn up with a
photographer to do that and uh put it
out and i don't think the queen would
allow it anyway how damaging have they
been those two with their antics i mean
i have a view that people know but what
do you think well the upper winfrey
interview was the thing that turned me
off them immediately because some of the
lies in that that were told some of the
untruths and misleading statements
certainly about archie's colour arches
skin you know i mean when that remark
was made it wasn't even engaged it
wasn't even talking about having a child
but the way it came across in the
interview it looked like it had been
discussed while she was pregnant but of
course it wasn't and then talking to
people of mixed race
they say to me they discuss if they were
having a baby
a chinese couple i know a lady married
to a chinese lady they discussed with my
eyes and i think it all depends on the
context we've never been told in context
bonnie i know that you're a supporter of
megan and harry my views are well known
arthur shares those views about this i i
felt from that interview onwards they've
been on a very strange journey where for
a couple that left the country for
privacy they've never stopped doing
media stuff
for a couple who
trash the monarchy in the institution
they keep using their royal titles to
commercially benefit themselves to the
tune of tens of millions of dollars so
i'm pretty cynical about what they've
done
you think i'm wrong well you know no
you're not wrong to be if you want to be
cynical but i think what we're
forgetting here is that this family is
probably one of the most resilient
uh pr exercises of at least the 20th
century remember they pulled off one of
the biggest brand coups of the 20th
century by changing their name from a
german name to the name of their their
residence they also uh pulled off
another coup
when um uh around the funeral the
princes of wales i mean they've been
changing all the time while giving
people the illusion that they haven't i
mean they're absolutely brilliant and
this will be handled too i mean i don't
know why people are freaking out so much
about this
uh this is this family exists and
survives because they can't adapt and
it's too bad that the people who support
them don't know how to do that
themselves yeah i mean i think after
if you go back over your time covering
the rules four decades there have been a
lot of big royal scandals i mean we we
feel like because of social media the
megan and harry antics and prince andrew
and so on have been really big but there
have been as we know from that
documentary last night the abdication of
a king over a love affair probably
dwarfed any of this that's right and
they went on to live in america but they
never dumped on the royal family not
once they they never did it
there were
into the royal family
and and it's true
that family edward i mean sorry the the
duke of windsor and the duchess of
windsor
cashed in it is not even in comparison
to what megan and harry are doing well
yeah but the point they were paid they
were paid to go to nightclubs they had
all kinds of things
what they never did after said which is
true they never attacked the royal
family in public and i would have no
problem
if megan and harry gave up their titles
and just lived off being megan and
harry's celebrities
you're forgetting one thing
this guy gave up
the crown yeah he didn't have that that
was the coup
d'etat right there so he already
attacked the royal family okay that was
done and probably done for all time okay
okay you don't have to do anything
you're making good points and i don't
dispute that thank you katie i mean this
goes back to my point to arthur
we have gone through you know centuries
of royal scandal i mean imagine this
social media been around with henry viii
beheading his wife i mean it's all
relative you know it's all relative but
i think it's the way the queen has
weathered these storms i mean look at
the death of diana and the way that
almost you know saw the tide really
nearly turn against the queen she
reigned that back here i i spoke to
someone for my new book who said to me
excellent by the way the new royals very
good read this was this was so important
he said to me the queen has the most
remarkable capacity for
for forgiveness and i think that's what
you're going to see with the suspects
she wants this japanese
i've met the queen a couple of times and
i'll tell you one one occasion i met her
which i thought was extraordinary this
was the reopening of windsor castle okay
this this place had burned down there
were people in there smoking now that
was my house i would have said hold it
cut it out my place has already burned
down you people are lighting up
cigarettes that was when we were allowed
people were allowed to do that she walks
in
she walks around you know you can't talk
to her you have to be taken over to her
and then she gains to speak
people walking through people's smoke
everything cool as a cucumber i wouldn't
worry about her at all i mean nothing
but nothing flusters the queen certainly
not in public
i wanted to show you a picture it's a
stonehenge which they lit up with eight
pictures images beamed onto stonehenge
of the queen through the years i thought
this was a wonderful
idea didn't you i do i do too i had a
print made today one of my favorite
pictures of the queen i'm going to put
up in the window of my house tonight you
know i'm very excited about it yeah
everywhere you know it's uh what's your
favorite memory of the queen personally
oh personally well when she gave me my
my uh mbe when she uh she said i can't
believe i'm giving you this she said
she'd give it to me and uh and there's
so long you've been coming down here to
photograph me i'll say then it was 20
years ago i said 27 years ma'am
she said oh let's have our picture
tighten together oh that was really
amazing yeah and that really was moving
i've never forgotten that and yeah
and funny as i walked away prince andrew
came up to me said oh what did you get i
said nbe he said what does that stand
for i said much bigger expenses
it's a privilege to have you you're one
of the all-time great royal
photographers and you still do it and i
won't ask you how old you are but i know
and it's amazing the energy and drive
you still have for your your craft thank
god
it's a nice job a nice people i work
with lovely people so royal tours are
always the most fun with arthur of
course everything's brilliant
everything's more fun with arthur katie
thank you very much the new royals is
out now queen elizabeth legacy in
november in november i'm sorry coming
out you got it first in november first
early copy okay cool and bonnie greer
thank you very much indeed that was
quite civilized for us i thought
[Laughter]
no comment from bonnie she's not she's
not agreeing or otherwise no no i i i no
it was civilized because at the end of
the day
they're going to come anyway so that's
that you know i mean that's that and
it'll all be over
bonnie great to see you come back thank
you pierce thank you take care of
yourself
i says the next legendary jockey frankie
dettori on her majesty's love of forces
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
the queen's level horse racing is well
known and the summer legendary jockey
frankie dettori has set his sights
firmly on riding a royal ascot winner
for her majesty the italian joined me to
reflect on writing 50 winners for the
monarch over the last 30 years frankie
good evening to you
hi pierce i want to start frankie this
one won and now
i just want to say i'm going to wait for
my last one
did you win the last one
no i want the first one but now now i'm
gonna write the next one in the next 20
minutes well the normal package
you know frankie is that whatever
whenever i bet on you to win you always
lose and when i don't burn on you to win
yeah please stop
stop betting on me stop better than me
uh frankie i know that you and the queen
are very close you've ridden so many
rides for her you've won so many races
for us she loves the horse racing and
obviously today is a bit of sweet day
because we had all these amazing
celebrations and i was hoping to just
talk about that with you but we can't
ignore the breaking news which is that
she's had some discomfort tonight and
she won't be attending the thanksgiving
service at saint paul's cathedral
tomorrow what's your reaction to that
well
you know when when you look at the
queen's schedule this next uh for three
or four days i mean it's really
so much
uh we we forget that you know she's a a
great old age of 96 and she's also i
think she's going to miss the
the derby on saturday that is probably
the first time in over 50 years but you
know we all wished well and
and just perhaps
you know just pace itself a little bit
it's very easy for us to say but uh i
think we asked
a lot from her
yeah and i think there were genuine
concerns she may not have made any of
the jubilee celebrations i was told by
somebody very close to the royals about
six weeks ago they were really worried
about it so the fact she was able to be
on the balcony today i think was huge
she will obviously miss the derby you're
you're right you're racing the derby in
fact i think you were gonna be on one of
the queen's horses but the horse got
pulled is that right
yes unfortunately said that my mind has
stepped back he's not gonna make it but
uh you know it was great to see her
majesty and the balcony smiling with all
that with all the family and uh you know
we wish you well and uh and you know it
was gonna be an amazing platinum jubilee
and
we're going to go ahead and race the
derby i'm sure she's going to watch it
on tv and
we're going to try to give majesty a
great spectrum of horse racing because
what she loves very much one of my
favorite stories frankie involved you
the queen and the late great lester
piggett who very sadly died uh several
days ago one of the all-time great
jockeys like you are and it involved the
uh king george vi where i think you you
got a little above yourself didn't you
and you you boasted to the queen that
you'd won it four times
and she replied that's nothing lester
won it seven times
correct when i went up to the podium to
pick up the trophy and uh i said uh your
majesty i want it four times and she
looked at me well less than what is
seven times
get back to you get back in your box so
you know she's got a great session and
you know as you know she loves racing
roy alaska the derby all that so
you know she's been a great ambassador
for my sport and just a word about
lester piggett because he was an amazing
jockey he was an erasable uncompromising
courageous you know very individual kind
of character
but an amazing story where he ended up
going to prison for uh tax evasion
issues and then he made his comeback age
55 and he won the breeders cup in
america at 55
in racing terms how big a deal was that
frankie
i i i was actually i was in that race uh
uh actually unfortunately i started
riding leicester already retired he had
five years
off racing and a couple of those years
he spent in prison and then after 12
days he came back from from from riding
goes to new york and wins the british
cup one of the biggest race in the world
a 54 year old man he was an amazing man
and don't forget we're gonna race the
derby
in memory of him on saturday
and uh he's won the
kazoo absolutely nine times what what an
amazing man and
would never be beaten yeah an amazing an
amazing guy great character let's talk
about you and the queen
sorry this appears i i i must stop you
because my horses are here i have to go
to ride the next way so
i wish you all the best friend i wish i
could talk to you a bit longer go win it
and go with it go win it for the queen
even though it's not a queen source go
win it for the queen and dedicate your
win to the queen thank you for taking
time in between races go get them
frankie all the best
[Music]
[Applause]
i declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
[Applause]
well today's trivia color was british
pomp and pageantry at its very best 1400
parading soldiers 400 musicians 200
horses and thousands of royal superfans
lining the mouth i'm joined now by
captain jonathan brooks of the king's
troop horse artillery who was present on
horse guards parade today and then fired
the 41 gun salute from hyde park captain
thank you so much for joining me after
your extraordinary day it's the first
proper troop in the color you've done in
front of all the crowds
first question what was it like
i mean it was amazing yeah i managed to
do the um juvenile color last year at
windsor castle but this year was
spectacular really felt like a moment in
history with the crowds absolutely
packing them out
and the royal family there in full force
it was simply spectacular and of course
trooping the colour is you know for
several hundred years now celebrated the
queen's birthday or the monarch's
birthday of the time
what does it mean to you as a serving
member of the armed forces to be
honoring the queen the head of the armed
forces in this way
i mean it's a tremendous privilege she
is a huge inspiration to all of us she
puts duty ahead of everything else and
she really for us essentially feels at
the heart of the nation so to be able to
be there and be a big part of marking
this historic occasion and hopefully
making her proud is is unbeatable really
the crowds were huge they were really
exuberant today is a lot of patriotism
and flag waving and joy in the air after
all we've been through as a country in
recent years it was a really lovely day
to just say
we're british we're great we're proud of
our country and we're proud of our queen
yeah we we do pomp in so many
you know out the best in the world we
are top of the top of the game when it
comes to pomp and ceremony and the
public were really behind us um they
were quite funny going down the mall
every time our trumpeters blew a trumpet
call they absolutely loved it and i put
a big smile on our faces although we had
to try not to smile but you know they
were superb and it was great to see
everyone there and to your credit none
of you fainted in the heat i hear
no we managed to survive the heat it was
was a hot day we were playing with some
merciless crowd cloud cover but it does
look spectacular horse guards prayed in
the sun so i'm glad that the sun came
out for us it was fantastic and you guys
did a great job and the raf were
fantastic as well it was a brilliant i
was there right at buckingham palace and
it was really
the pomp the pageantry the military all
of it coming together with the royal
family what a wonderful day it was and i
thank you and all your colleagues well
for what you did today but also for your
service to your country thank you very
much captain brooks
oh
cheers thanks very much pearce
and says the next he's a vibrant
alternative national hero thanks to his
outspoken on his statements he's also
about as uncensored as a human being can
get former sex pistol front man john
ryden aka johnny rotten will be here
live and very much unleashed
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
regime
[Music]
[Applause]
she ain't no human being
oh that's sex pistols one of the
all-time great anarchic bands can listen
to that all day fortunately we've got
one of the men behind it
johnny rotten john lydon the great man
here here live peace unleash great to
see you
uh we're gonna be doing a regular
catch-up with you called johnny's rotten
world because the last time he came on
it popped so well on youtube everyone
was watching this they love your
unvarnished uncensored view of life well
i like to tell it as he is yeah you know
i'm not influenced by the media yeah
but they are very seriously influenced
by me yes
you just can't be rehearsing with your
new bad pill today in london yeah i'm
straight out of rehearsal so forgive me
if i look a bit sweaty and moist
the girlies apparently like it that way
did i ask you about politics for a
moment because you said something quite
interesting in the last few days you
talked about how it used to be the right
that was seen to be the completely
intolerant
fascists who never allowed people to
have different opinions and so on and
now it's gone full circle oh it's
absolutely to the left swings and
roundabouts now in it i can't trust
anything coming out of labour anymore i
i i began to despise them really yeah
it's too they this woke agenda and all
of this nonsense i can't be tolerating
that you know
i'd rather vote conservative because at
least i i can rely on their hypocrisy
but i don't want to vote for lunacy
it's plain and simple when you see the
debate over boris johnson and these
parties
are really the core of it it's just that
they were all partying in downing street
when they were telling everybody else
you can't go and see your dying
relatives
that white man speak with fork tongue
you know
do you think he's a liar boris oh
completely
so you know if you're going to write
these laws in and insist on them and
then deliberately go and break them
yourself well that's that kind of
hypocrisy is is just a little unfeasible
for me so sod him you know he's like all
politicians really a professional liar
but by god that bloke bone you had on
there defending him wow what a piece of
work
he reminded me of that old tory kind of
creature that i used to really really
hate and loathe so you know get rid of
both of them and things might be on the
look up but on top of that
i would like a prime minister that is
capable of partying but then don't be
introducing laws that you're not going
to follow yourself and expect the rest
of us to oblige right it's the hypocrisy
is the problem right it's wicked wicked
i wish i was at that party though
i think you're delivering it up
[Laughter]
what do you mean we're in obviously
jubilee week and god said the queen was
this iconic anthem at the time it was
all about anarchy and so on you've
you've softened a little bit over the
years is that right you say about the
queen in particular no no this is the
media again trying to uh take the
destination out of the the h bomb i
dropped on that song uh i'm as uh
as uh solid about monarchy and my uh
dislike of it as i ever have been to me
i've always viewed the royal family as a
bunch of german and tourists with a
greek thrown in you know
but as a human being right she ain't no
human being as representing his state
she doesn't represent me i don't want to
pay no more tax to keep that institution
alive but i totally respect her as a
real person that she's endured that and
maintained yes a sense of dignity and
i'm always attracted to pageantry and
this is you know i grew up loving the
arsenal and if we weren't waving our
flags that's as close to pageantry as
you can get there's also something i
just think we look at the way politics
has gone around the world really it's so
so much corruption so much hypocrisy so
much you know really incredible
characters getting to run countries yeah
and you think at least in the queen's
case you've got this woman who's barely
put her foot wrong she's dignified she's
humble and so she's controlling all of
that yeah you know what i mean it's like
it's almost if you just view her as a
sort of calming figurehead for the
country she's been one of the most
impressive people that we've ever had i
would say
but god bless if she kicks the bucket
what's going to follow well that is a
genuine problem i mean tonight we have
the archbishop of canterbury saying that
for example we should not be looking to
forgive people like prince andrew that
he's shown that he wants to make amends
for what he did but my issue with that
first of all find him guilty before you
forgive right
is it and the archbishop of canterbury i
mean i'm sorry but that has the ring of
child molester about it
you mean in terms of the way that the
church the church all of these
institutions and of course they all
cover themselves up but as i say first
find him guilty of something he's
obviously he's hiding something
i don't trust him and when you have a
when you have the queen's son
who pays millions of dollars yeah to a
woman who was accusing him
of having
in america underage sex with her and
being involved in sex trafficking with a
pedophile
when he does that having said i'm going
to fight this and clear my name even
though
he didn't even though there was no guilt
attached to this settlement the fact
he's had to pay millions of dollars what
does it say a settlement is telling you
everything
it's almost like a bribe to go away
isn't it
now the poor lady in question i mean
she knew what they'd like they'd rip her
apart in courts basically you know so
take this cash under under hand
it's victimization again and if that if
that's going on in the future royal
family i don't want none of them can you
forgive somebody in this circumstance if
they don't accept
what they did when we don't even know
what he actually did because he won't
you won't say can you offer forgiveness
if people don't show any atonement for
what they may have done
no it is a holier than thou about it uh
i just won't be tolerating there's
something there just
bring it out wash your dirty laundry in
public and let us be the judge of that
right
deals going on
this is the continual world they're
introducing us into isn't it complete
corruption
well i'd like to see a brave new world i
i do think it's caused uncalculable
damage to the
royals because i think that we've never
had a situation where the senior royal
has been involved in the settlement like
this and it's not like it was a you know
sort of financially i think we have seen
royals in the past histories have
definitely involved in normal
in modern times is what i would say and
it's a serious matter you know jeffrey
epstein was a disgusting billionaire
running up no not at all and my real
issue with it is that the andrew carried
on seeing that guy after he admitted and
was convicted of paedophile behavior
yeah there's all manner of money
laundering possibilities lurking in the
background right too like why did he
carry on being his friend you know
this is my taxpayer money it's right
it's being spent right now
bugger off
right no but i think i think it's a
legitimate reaction that most people
have to it what what do you think about
the jubilee celebrations are you going
to get involved you're going to be in a
street party are we going to see the man
who sang god save the queen singing it
with love and affection
why not
i love the party side of it right yeah
and the pageantry and everything
pageantry and the flag waving and being
part of a wonderful bloody country
they've got no shame but plenty of pride
about britain and i'll wave the flag any
way i like safety pins included do we
talk down the country too much i think
so i do yeah
that lady's done no personal harm to me
the institution has and and it's
obviously riddled with corruption
you know
i i just pity what comes after her it
just i've got no hope for it i think we
should uh really uh
start voting on a new queen
really yeah let's have an election who
would you fancy meghan markle oh someone
from australia
i want to ask you about something else
top gum so i got very excited yesterday
about talking i went to see top i loved
the new movie i loved the first one and
to me it restored
masculinity and being a man yeah
do you see anything in this well i'll
tell you there's a shortage of modern
war movies right and uh you do need
those kind of characters really if your
country is going to survive any threats
of invasion you need proper blokes to
sort it out
and trying to sweep that under the
carpet with this new era of woke is
unacceptable to me
we need men's men i'm sorry but that's
just the way it is and this is idea that
masculinity itself is wrong oh toxic
it's all toxic yeah i'll have a vodka
and toxic masculinity
it does annoy me because of course there
are some men who are toxic but there are
also many men who can show masculine
qualities which actually not only are
good qualities but women like men to be
masculine because that's human nature
right right and and to go against nature
really shows like a major flaw and a
weakness in the idiocy that's coming
from extreme left politics i i i find it
very very alarming that young students
are so quick to jump on this like a name
slurry business without really thinking
the thing through but also i think the
idea of students but they're all dressed
as men and women themselves yeah but
they're arguing against but this idea
that a minister can go there who's only
said that he believes a woman is an
adult female and for that he has to be
hounded with abuse
because you actually have labor mps now
women mps saying actually women can have
penises
well of course they can that's how you
get babies
but
i sort of feel the world's gone mad a
bit if you're working against nature
because of some new political fandangled
theory then you're a bit of a fool and
i'm afraid the young are very very
foolish in this and i must say not all
young just those who've gone through the
university systems they seem to uh not
be educated anymore but really
institutionalize i want to play we do a
little segment called world's got most
of them should be in an institution
we do a regular thing called world's
gone nuts i think you're going to like
this story john because this is actually
something normally at the end of the
show i'm going to play it now watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
now this is a a love story that might
not take off
it involves 22 year old sarah rhoda who
lives in dortmund germany and she's
announced that she's in love with a
boeing 737
passenger jet and has plans to wed said
to jet the future mrs 737 identifies as
an objectum sexual meaning she's
attracted to inanimate objects and has
50 replicas of the flying love machine
unsurprisingly it's not legal to
actually marry a replica aircraft in
germany but neither the law nor common
sense to stop other people from doing
things like this in 2007 erica labrie
married the eiffel tower changing her
last name to eiffel and kate cunningham
has been happily married to a tree for
nearly three years but true love never
does run smoothie poor akihiko condo who
married a hologram character has been
has been left devastated after the
expiration of the software meant he
could no longer talk to his father
john
when you look at stuff like this i in a
way it's a kind of wonderful thing that
there are people this mad out there
right i think so and i find that
entertaining but the the shocking one
really for me was the girl fondling the
747
that's one up on a battery operated
penis
and god bless her if that if that's what
turns her on it rings her bell you know
john i can talk to you all night
fortunately we've only got to wait two
weeks till you're back on it's been
brilliant to have you on please in our
sense that you are as unsensitive as it
gets i thank god for somebody who just
speaks their mind and doesn't care what
all you canceled culture wokey say
because you can't cancel a sex pistol
right you certainly can't and i'm on
tour with public image limited to prove
it y'all come on down now
shut up your mouth
[Laughter]
yes sir
everybody the winner
every two weeks from now on because i
cannot interview this guy enough this is
what we want in life plain talking
straight talking
uncensored so easy to just tell the
truth isn't it it is and yet it's not
easy for a lot of people and i thank god
people like you are doing it and i'll do
it too and hopefully we'll put the world
to right good to see you john what's my
last figure boris rules are for fools
and he's proved the point by breaking
his own
i think that's probably perfectly sums
it up
that's it for me whenever you go to this
weekend make sure it's uncensored
[Music]
please
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
what gets too much air time bland
beige
unopinionated dross
i think the british public
wants to be able to be of an opinion
want to be able to be involved that's
the great thing for me about talk to
people we'll be able to get involved i
just think that we misjudge the british
public if we tell them the whole time
what they should be thinking i am sick
and tired of watching television that
tells you what you should be thinking
talks at you rather than with you
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm holly hudson the queen
will not attend the epson derby tomorrow
instead buckingham palace announced that
she will watch the races which are part
of her platinum jubilee celebrations on
tv at windsor castle with princess anne
expected to take her place it comes
after her majesty was forced to pull out
of today's thanksgiving service due to
what the panis called discomfort during
yesterday's celebrations the service at
saint paul's cathedral was attended by
senior royals and the duke and duchess
of sussex who made their first public
appearance in the uk in two years and
uefa has issued what it calls a sincere
apology to fans following the chaos at
last week's champions league final in a
statement they said no football fan
should be put in that situation that's
all for now we'll have more after the
talk
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you